Painting from broad areas into smaller areas, into details.
So you start painting to be very dark and bright, and then modulate, modulate the colors.
When you said darker greens, you said, or shades of cave, everything, anything?
Yeah.
The theory is, um, um, do it in, you know, Rich, why don't you take the glass from, from out there?
Okay.
This guy is, he's a bastard in the back.
He wouldn't want to talk to me when he was a man.
Okay.
We, we can check it out afterwards, but this, this store closes very early, so we have to go there.
And the, and the reason why I want to start it here, and we're coming there, is because
if you want to do all these activities, and, um, you can just do all these activities, and
most of my budget will go to getting to Airbnb, and the occasional rental car for when you go,
see the, and see the building that's, and the community is going to, like, I want to stay as much as possible, and, if I can, I'll just, if I can.
I'll just, if I can, I'll just, if I can, I'll just, if I can, I'll just, if I can, I'll just use this thing.
Okay.
I mean, that's fine, right? I'm not in the room.
I'm not in the room.
Okay.